one of the best things on TV is in
practical jokers a hidden-camera show
featuring four lifelong friends who
challenge each other to engage in
embarrassing situations because of the
revealing nature of the show there are
very few parts of the Joker's private
lives that aren't on public display but
here are a few things you may not have
known about America's Funniest friends
comic book man
AMC's comic book men almost featured
another member but Brian Q Quinn was
stuck in truTV's contractual grip and
couldn't join his good friends on Kevin
Smith's nerdy version of Pawn Stars q a
lifelong fan of comics appears regularly
on a podcast called tell'em Steve Dave
with comic book man's Walt Flanagan and
Brian Johnson Q's first girlfriend
astute viewers will note that Q is
mentioned that his first girlfriend
spent some time in prison and that she's
the half-sister of an a-list celebrity I
know who it is she is alive and
breathing out of respect for the
delicate family situation Q's never
mentioned her by name on the air however
dedicated redditors have used
information from the show and Q's
podcast to limit the possibilities to a
very specific area at a very specific
time and deduced that Q dated King of
Queen star Lea remedies half-sister
Elizabeth who was arrested in 2005 for
felonious cocaine trafficking but you
didn't hear it from us Brian swollen
brain there are a few Joker's episodes
where it was very clear that Q was
suffering from an illness and at least
one challenge that Q was allowed to skip
because of health concerns viewers
didn't know that Q's problems were far
worse than the flu and after a battery
of invasive tests administered by four
doctors a regiment of serious
antibiotics and a misdiagnosis of Lyme
disease Q found out that he was actually
suffering from serious encephalitis and
meningitis the difference between pre
and post illness Q was about 15 pounds
and Joker's filming was put off for
about a week one last ride that was
night-night forever
see you soon MA full cup between 2010
and 2014 joker Sal Vulcano was part of
full cup a beloved music venue and bar
in his native Staten Island
unfortunately the location ran into
financial trouble in 2014 and rebranded
itself as hash tag bar in early 2016
Sal mentioned the bar in his 2013 reddit
AMA but once the bar started to crash
and burn in 2014 he made a public
statement saying he hadn't been involved
in operations for more than a year he
ditched the struggling business taking
his finance degree with him and
completely embraced his new life of TV
torture Sal's tats one of the most
memorable punishments in Joker's history
involved three of the cast members
getting tattoos termed by Joe Gatto who
was the only winner of that week's
challenge while Q and Murr tattoos were
meaningful to their lives in a sarcastic
way Sal's tattoo was a huge picture of
Jaden Smith on his thigh viewers will
also notice that Sal already had quite a
few tattoos at this point including
tribal bands around his calves his arm
tattoo however has a pretty deep meaning
to him it's song lyrics dedicated to a
friend that he lost in 2011 kind of
makes that Jaden tattoo look especially
cruel slap attack even though most of
the pranks on Joker's are designed only
to embarrass the four stars there have
been plenty of times where they've
almost come to blows with the
unsuspecting public and twice when they
did anyone who watches the show knows
that all four friends are really polite
respectful guys but Sal was once slapped
when he was forced to tell a woman that
her baby was ugly and also choked by a
man that he cut in line as part of a
challenge apologies were quickly
dispensed and neither segment aired cry
diving Murr is most notable punishment
and the inspiration for his tattoo was
being forced to skydive despite a
serious fear of heights
on air we seamer run and threatened to
quit the show but what we don't see is
the hour he spent locked in a bathroom
refusing to come out while he sent
farewell text to his friends and family
sure that he would not survive the
experience both Murr and Sal share a
fear of heights which they face again
during their later charitable tightrope
walk Murr TV in their tour documentary
The Joker's credit James Murray is being
the unstoppable force behind getting
Impractical Jokers on the air despite
being a reality TV star merce still
maintains his day job as the senior VP
of development of north-south
productions which explains why he's the
only Joker too busy to have his own
podcast even though he could host one in
any of the 17 languages he claims to be
able to speak that is when he's not shat
full of Novocain braised beef is
brilliant isn't it braised meat braised
beef braised beef is brilliant I'll set
it once I'll say it again I said it once
I'll say it again thanks for watching
subscribe to our youtube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which Joker's moment is your
favorite